oh my goodness you guys right now I'm in
New York for a little Meetup here to see
the new Max that they just launched they
announced not just one chip three chips
the new M3 the M3 Pro and the M3 Pro
Max and obviously as a huge Mac User I
canot be more excited because for the
past year the M2 MacBook Pro has
completely changed my life it is my main
computer that I use for almost
everything even though I have the
incredible powerful studio with the
amount that I travel this MacBook can
literally do everything that I need and
so much more so I can't wait to test
these out speaking of testing them out I
haven't got to do just that yet but I
did get a chance to see the new color
it's the new space black MacBook Pro and
it looks so fresh I mean check out this
color and again this comes in two
different sizes we have the 14-in and
the 16-in and they also have a little
gaming room where we can get a chance to
play some games not only do we have new
Macbook Pros but we now have the all new
iMac lineup again the iMac hasn't been
updated since the M1 so now we've got
the allnew M3 iMac there's so much cool
stuff here and again this is like
Halloween Eve so it's so festive and I'm
having the best time let's go check it
[Music]
out
oh man this is the most fun Mac event
ever I mean this is like a
[Music]
party this is so cute okay this is the
candy shop there's a menu so they
obviously announced the new IMAX with
the M3 chip and of course it is
Halloween so on theme we're in the
little candy shop with all of the
colorful IMAX let's order some snacks I
made it a whole day without eating candy
here we are
again is that decoration that's
decoration you think it's candy I don't
know if that's decoration or not but I
don't even like candy corn but I'm
getting it white chocolate pretzels
absolute
[Music]
fave shopping 14-in MacBook M3 Mac yes
164 CPU
baby that's that's a lot of extra money
yes 8 tab solid sa add the bag oh shoot
I have an iPhone in my cart also let me
remove that and there we go estimated
delivery November 15th and November 17th
can't
[Music]
wait so we have the 16-in MacBook Pro
and the new 14-in Macbook Pro these are
the new M3s and this is the new color
it's the space black I'm so excited that
they announced this new color cuz I feel
like it really freshens up the pro line
so I just realized that I've been
calling it The M3 Pro Max it's the M3
Max but you guys know what I mean
there's three of them there's the M3 the
M3 Pro and the M3 max if you do want the
new space black color this only comes in
the M3 Pro and the M3 Max version so if
you do get the base model M3 you aren't
able to get the new colors that is
definitely a reason for an upgrade it's
also pretty incredible that the pro and
the max chips you'll be able to spec
these out to 128 gigs of RAM I was
hoping that they would up the internal
storage but you can spec them out to 8
terab which definitely will be doing
that as
[Music]
well so I'm not going to lie I think
this is one of my most favorite Keynotes
that they've done granted it was very
short and they only announced a few
things but it was so cool seeing them do
a spooky scary theme so I'm looking
forward to getting a chance to get
Hands-On with these devices so be sure
to check back here subscribe like
comment and I will see you guys in the
next video I'm going to go eat my candy
bye